jeder Mensch braucht ein Zuhause das ist
sozusagen genauso wichtig wie der Zugang
zur Arbeit zu Bildung zu Gesundheit zu
Energie und wenn wir in der Lage kommen
dass Menschen die jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig viel verdienen ihre Wohnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen können ihre Miete
nicht mehr bezahlen können die
Nebenkosten nicht mehr zu bezahlen
können dann ist Start gefordert dort
entsprechend einzugreifen die
Bundesregierung hatte ja große Pläne
400.000 Wohnungen und pro Jahr sollten
gebaut werden das hat sie nicht
geschafft hat sie nicht annähernd
geschafft und das hat dramatische Folgen
vor allen Dingen hat sich im sozialen
Wohnungsbau nicht geschafft jedes Jahr
gegen mehr soziale Wohnungen und
Sozialwohnungen raus aus der Förderung
aus der auch aus der Bindung als
Sozialwohnungen als neue hinzukommen und
um das zu stoppen ähm sind wir der
festen Überzeugung dass wir eine neue
wohngemeinnützigkeit brauchen und dass
wir
kommunale Wohnungsbaugesellschaften
brauchen die wir hier zum Beispiel in
Berlin haben die ist aber auch in vielen
anderen Gemeinden und in vielen anderen
Ländern gibt die verstärkte soziale
Wohnungen und Sozialwohnungen bauen die
verstärkt auch entsprechend ausgestattet
werden damit sie das finanzieren können
um so Wohnungen anbieten zu können die
auch tatsächlich für jeden Geldbeutel
bezahlbar sind und das kann man
natürlich Staffeln je nach je nach nach
Einkommen aber wir sind der Auffassung
niemand soll mehr als 30% seines
Einkommens für die Wohnung für die Miete
zahlen müssen weil es braucht ja noch
mehr im Leben als nur zu wohnen wobei
wohnen wirklich ein ein ganz zentrale
ganz zentrale
Angelegenheit ist wenn man kein Zuhause
hat dann ist man unsicher dann fühlt man
sich nicht wohl dann hat man eigentlich
auch keine Chance im Beruf erfolgreich
zu sein oder in der Bildung erfolgreich
zu sein und bleibt auch nicht gesund ist
das die Lösung ist dass die Lösung der
Stadt baut Wohnungen vermietet die
günstiger ich glaube nicht dass man
nimmt stark überträgt kann eine Lösung
sein weil der startet das ja verkorkst
ich bin vollkommen eher der Meinung
ausnahmsweise dass das Wohnen eines der
wichtigsten Bedürfnisse ist dass man den
Markt auch nicht überlassen kann aber
ich sein Staatsversagen der Berliner
Senat will jetzt die Wohnungen
zurückkaufen die er selber vor 20 Jahren
verkauft hat zu sehr ungünstigen
Bedingungen und das ist nicht nur in
Berlin so und Sie werden keine
Erleichterung finden wenn Sie die
Aufgaben dem Staat übertragen es wird
nur länger dauern und mehr kosten nicht
vom Staat ich rede von kommunalen
Wohnungen eingreifen aber sind aber
Unternehmen die werden wir Unternehmen
geführt also schauen Sie sich mal hier
gerade wenn sie sie sind ja auch aus
Berlin schauen Sie sich mal hier um die
sechs landeseigenen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften arbeiten sehr
genau und die Arbeiten auch
wirtschaftlich und sind trotzdem in der
Lage bezahlbaren Wohnraum
bereitzustellen da sind wo sie Recht
haben wo sie Recht haben
es wird zurzeit viel weniger gebaut als
sie ja weil aber deswegen sagen wir ja
auch wir müssen den Schwerpunkt auf den
kommunalen Wohnungsbau legen weil die
privaten sich vom Bau zurückgezogen
haben das lohnt sich für Sie im Moment
auch eine Verschiebung der Verantwortung
sind gestiegen die Zinsen sind gestiegen
die privaten bauen keine Sozialwohnungen
nur zehn Prozent der Förderung die wir
hier im Land Berlin bereitstellen gehen
an private die beantragen ist gar nicht
weil es sich für sie nicht lohnt
Sozialwohnungen zu bauen weil
ich bitte nicht deswegen sagen
wir müssen die Förderung die wir haben
und noch mehr unseren landeseigenen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften unseren
Genossenschaften zur Verfügung stellen
damit sie günstig Kredite bekommen haben
mehr sozialen
wohnungsbundesländer
hier in Berlin wird genau das machen
also Berlin ist ja gerade das Beispiel
wie es nicht funktioniert sollte also
sie haben hier in Berlin mietendeckel
eingeführt und gesagt immer mehr
Sozialismus und immer mehr mit linker
Politik
wenn man diese Probleme lösen das
Ergebnis waren das Ergebnis war und das
das Ergebnis Frau Schubert war dass die
Wohnungsbau Zahlen massiv eingebrochen
sind es gab immer mehr immer weniger
Wohnung es stehen hier hunderte Leute
bei der Wohnung wenn die mal frei ist
alle wollen rein und in anderen Städten
da sieht es deutlich besser aus weil man
da auf andere Ansätze gesetzt hat da hat
man alle an einen da hat man alle an
einen Tisch geholfen halten
Schießbefehl gegeben
einmal zuhören er im ländlichen Bereich
ihre Praxis war schön Ihnen die Menschen
gibt es dort anders sind viele Menschen
die Existenz
gibt natürlich auch Wohnprobleme
Studenten also es ist natürlich eine
Katastrophe ähm ich sehe auch in meiner
eigentlichen Heimatstadt das ist eine
kleine Odenwald Gemeinde was ein
riesiges Baugebiet erschlossen wurde wo
ausgelost wurde nach social Credit
Points sehr wer jetzt im Bauplatz
bekommt und was ist alle haben fast alle
haben zurückgezogen ja weil also die
Preise zu hoch geworden sind also ich
glaube das ist alles auch ein Problem
dass die Leute einfach auch zu wenig
Geld haben und Reise explodiert und das
real,-
nicht mein Fachgebiet und soweit ich
sehe halt nur dass in Deutschland glaube
ich der Wohlstand zurückgeht und ich das
ist das muss ist erfolgreich
das ist ja da haben sie recht da haben
sie recht also nicht die Schere geht
auseinander definitiv und das ist Folge
von
schlechtere die auseinander geht in
ihrer Praxis beispielsweise das ist
schon zu spüren ja und es wird es wird
schwieriger es wird schwieriger für die
Leute einfach genügend übrig zu haben
dass sie vielleicht noch richtig
verklein ist dann zum Schluss leisten
können das wird immer schwieriger werden
ich glaube auch dass wenn eine
Entwicklung haben die das noch
problematischer macht und das ist nicht
das einfach nur die Runde werfen ich bin
aber da ist wirklich kein Experte das
ist Folge von von schlechter Politik ja
also auf den Wohlstand der Bürger zu
achten und und das die die Chance haben
sich etwas aufzubauen das ist im Zeichen
von guter Politik und man sieht ja schon
unterschiedlich in Deutschland also wir
haben hier in Berlin ein großes
Wohnungsproblem das Leben natürlich auch
das liegt natürlich vor allem auch am
rot rot grün Senat
und es soll alle staatlich zugeteilt
werden die alternativ Antwort wäre dass
sie sich Gedanken gemacht hätten wie
kann das Angebot an Wohnung vergrößert
werden das ist dann Marktwirtschaft und
dadurch würden die Preise sinken und die
Menschen hätten einfacher die
Möglichkeit eine Wohnung zu bekommen
sondern auch ihre Nebenkosten zahlen und
das muss noch mal angreifen
irgendwie für Kleinkinder ja man muss
nur genug bauen dann wird dann werden
die Preise schon sinken das ist falsch
wenn die Privaten nicht bereit sind
sie früher auch anders gedacht aber naja
ähm wenn wenn ist
bauen dann müssen wir über kommunale
Unternehmen Sozialwohnungen bauen damit
jeder eine entsprechen